Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Ich bin schon richtig am Strahlen weil - Was ist?
[Kiki] Warum lachst du mich aus?
[Hamza] Deine Hände waren so lang irgendwie!
Also, heute gibt es einen Blechkuchen bzw. einen Kuchen aus meinem Backrahmen
und das bedeutet immer, dass irgendwas Leckeres kommt! Ich liebe einfach diese Backrahmen-Kuchen!
[Hamza] Aber ehrlich! Immer, wenn du was im Backrahmen machst, dann klappt das.
[Kiki] Isso!
[Hamza] Isso!
Auf jeden Fall gibt es heute einen Kühlschrank-Kuchen mit einer sehr erfrischenden Schokocreme.
Also erfrischend weil ich benutze halt sehr gerne Mascarpone und Frischkäse im Mix.
Und da kann ich euch direkt vorab sagen: Benutzt bitte keinen sehr salzigen Frischkäse, keinen trockenen Frischkäse.
Verwendet z.B. Philadelphia, bei Mascarpone könnt ihr nichts falsch machen.
Und ich fange jetzt auch direkt an mit der Zubereitung.
Ihr findet alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung.
[Kiki] Ich habe hier in meiner großen Schüssel..
[Hamza] Geh mal zur seite!
[Kiki] Warum?
[Hamza] Die Hübsche will ich da sehen!
Ahh, mein Buch! Oh mein Gott, mein Buch ist da! Oh mein Gott!
Okay, aber dazu kommt ein extra Video!
Aber wir müssen das hier in diesem Video einmal appreciaten!
Dass es jetzt ab jetzt in jedem Video im Hintergrund steht, in jedem!
[Hamza] 2 Kikis auf einmal, die Doppelpackung! *lacht*
Ich gebe jetzt hier in meine große Schüssel, wo schon Mascarpone und Frischkäse drin sind,
einmal geschmolzene Vollmilchkuvertüre.
Ich hab das in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen bei 360W für 1-1½min
und anschließend 10min, also bevor wir angefangen haben, zu drehen, stehen lassen
weil sie sollte nicht mehr so heiß in die Mascarpone kommen bzw. in diese Mischung damit es sich super, super gut miteinander verbindet.
Und da gebe ich dann auch noch Zucker mit dazu.
Zucker, aber nur ein bisschen. Ich will's nicht zu süß.
Zum Schluss noch Backkakao hinzusieben und auch nochmal unterrühren.
Achtet gerne darauf, dass Mascarpone und Frischkäse nur noch Zimmertemperatur haben
und nicht mehr ganz kalt sind, denn dann lässt es sich einfacher verrühren und besser miteinander verbinden
Jetzt habe ich noch eine top Tipp für euch!
Der ist natürlich nur optional aber wenn ihr's grad da habt, dann gebt's auf jeden Fall rein,
denn der Geschmack ist danach so richtig, richtig auf einem ganz anderen Level!
Und zwar gebe ich da jetzt Kikis Cream Schoko mit rein.
Das ist meine Haselnuss-Schokocreme und die schmeckt super, super intensiv
und daher gebe ich da noch - Ist ein ganz neues Glas! -
und daher gebe ich da nochmal einen richtig großen Esslöffel von rein.
Und sobald ihr auch nur einen Esslöffel von der Kikis Cream in die große Schüssel gebt und das verrührt,
riecht ihr so richtig diese Haselnussaromen. Also riecht auch gerne mal dran!
Und falls ihr meine Creme schon da habt und auch schon probiert habt,
- Denn die meisten haben sie letzte Woche schon zugeschickt bekommen weil sie sie bestellt haben -
dann schreibt mir doch hier unten in die Kommentare, wie sie euch schmeckt.
Ich freue mich immer sehr über euer Feedback.
Und ich fange jetzt hier an, die Schlagsahne steif zu schlagen.
Dafür einfach mit der Küchenmaschine einmal anrühren und dann mit immer schneller werdender Geschwindigkeit steif schlagen
und Sahnefest einrieseln lassen.
Anders als jetzt hier bei der Mascarpone-Frischkäsemasse,
muss die Sahne ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank kommen damit sie sich auch steif schlagen lässt.
Die steif geschlagene Sahne dann mit einem Teigschaber in mehreren Schritten und mit ganz viel Liebe unterrühren
und dann ist die Creme auch schon fertig, die steht jetzt hier auch beiseite.
Und ich fange an mit meinen Eierbiskuits, das sind diese hier.
Ihr könntet auch Löffelbiskuits nehmen, ich mag die Eierbiskuits ganz gerne.
Und die tunke ich wirklich nur für 1 Sekunde in Milch.
Also wirklich nur so 1, dann wieder raus.
Und dann gebe ich sie in meinen Backrahmen, den habe ich eingestellt auf 24x26cm.
Aber ich schreibe euch die Infos alle sowieso unten in die Infobox.
Und ich persönlich habe unten drunter immer mein eckiges Cakeboard
aber ihr könnt auch direkt irgendeine andere Unterlage verwenden.
Hauptsache, wir müssen es danach nicht nochmal transportieren, das ist ganz wichtig.
So, und jetzt das Ganze abwechselnd schichten und oben schön glatt verstreichen.
Ich habe das grad nochmal kurz in den Kühlschrank gegeben weil ich jetzt den Guss draufgeben werde.
Und zwar habe ich hier Sahne einfach in meiner Pfanne aufgewärmt.
Ganz, ganz wichtig: Nicht hochkochen lassen, sonst wird das Ganze später zu flüssig.
Also wirklich nur erwärmen und dann gehackte Zartbitterkuvertüre reingeben
und das Ganze darin schön schmelzen lassen.
Das ist dann unser Guss, den wir dann drauf verteilen.
Und ich mache das so, dass ich später noch mit Erdbeeren und Pistazien dekoriere.
Und jetzt den Kuchen nochmal für 2h kühlen damit alles richtig schön sitzen kann und fest werden kann.
Und dann könnt ihr auch schon den Backrahmen entfernen - am besten mit einem Backrahmenmesser damit euch da auch nichts kaputt geht -
und das Ganze servieren!
Ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Tut mir leid, dass es heute keinen Taste Test gibt, während Ramadan ist das Ganze ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber wir machen den Taste Test mit Sicherheit auf Instagram
und dafür verlinke ich euch mal unsere Accounts unten in der Infobox
und wünsche euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!